مشاهدينا نعيد ونذكر بمجمل العواجل التي
كنا نتحدث عنها الان اذا مركز رصد زلازل
متوسطيه يتحدث عن هزه ارضيه قويه يشعر بها
سكان تركيا وسوريا ولبنان وفلسطين تتحدث
عن زلزال بقوه 6.3 يضرب منطقه الحدود
التركيه السوريه
وسماع اصوات انهيار ابنيه في انطاكيا
التركيه سنبقى في متابعه كل ذلك نتذكر
مشاهدينا باننا او نذكر باننا كنا في
متابعه ازمه حقيقيه شهدتها كل من جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا على اثر الزلزال الذي
كلف ارواح بالالاف
واعتبر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بانها كارثه لم تشهدها تركيا خلال قرن
اكثر من اربعين الف قتيل وهناك الاعداد
لازال مستمر من وراء هذه الكارثه التي
شهدتها تركيا وكذلك هناك احصائيات تخص
سوريا المناطق التابعه او التي تقع تحت
سيطره النظام السوري وهناك كذلك مناطق في
الشمال الغربي
لسوريا والتي يستمر او تستمر الجهود
لمحاوله ايصال المساعدات والتي تعطلت في
بدايه هذه الازمه كانت هناك محاولات
لادخال المساعدات عبر المعابر المفتوحه
وكذلك بعض المعابر التي تم اغلاقها لفتره
من الفترات ولكن نتظافرت الجهود ليتم او
لتكون هناك محاولات لادخال هذه المساعدات
الجانب التركي كذلك من جهته كانت هناك
انتقادات وجهتها المعارضه للجانب التركي
في تاخير اصول المساعدات لبعض المناطق من
بينها منطقه هاتاي التي شهدت انزلاقات
وشهدت يعني تدمير لعده مناطق فيها وكان
اعترف الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بارتباك اسماه ارتباك
شهدته حكومته على اثر هذا الزلزال في
الساعات الاولى من هذا الزلزال هذه صور
مشاهدينا
للزلزال الذي كنا نتحدث عنه ولكن الاكيد
باننا سنبقى في متابعه او في انتظار صور
الجديده التي ستضعنا في اطار ما يحدث في
تركيا وفي سوريا هذه صور قديمه نشير لها
الازمه لا زالت مستمره فكيف ستكون ان
نتحدث من جديد عن زلزال اخر هكذا اكدت
رويترز ومن قبلها مركز رصد الزلازل الاورو
متوسط الذي تحدث عن هزه ارضيه قويه شعر
بها سكان تركيا سوريا لبنان وفلسطين هذا
الزلزال قال بانه قوه سته فاصل اربعه
وبانه ضرب منطقه الحدود التركيه السوريه
واداره الكوارث التركيه اكدت بان هذا
الزلزال كان بقوه سته فاصل اربعه اذا هذه
الصور التي كنا بانتظارها هذه صور منها
تايم مشاهدينا ونلاحظ بان سكانها تايسارع
للخروج من منازلهم على اثر هذه الهزه
الارضيه التي قدرت اداره الكوارث التركيه
قوتها ب 6.4 واكدت بان مركز هذا الزلزال
هي منطقه دفني في هاتاي هذه هي الصور
الاوليه التي تصلنا من هاتاي وكنا نتابع
خروج المتسكنين نسمع لصوت الطبيعي ونعود
بعد ذلك
انا
دائما مع هذه الصور وينضم لنا الان من
انطاكيا عمر جبلاوي الصحفي السوري عمر انت
موجود في انطاكيا كنا نتابع صور لخروج
السكان وهز ارضيه تحدثت عنها اداره
الكوارث التركيه قالت بانها طالت تركيا
وسوريا كذلك وحثها سكان فلسطين ولبنان
حدثنا عن التفاصيل يا عمر
نحن نتحدث اليوم ليس عن هزه ارضيه
اعتياديه وارتداديه كما يحصل في الايام
السابقه ولكن نحن نتحدث اليوم عن زلزال
اخر اصاب ولايه هاتاي انطاكيا تحديدا في
منطقه الدفنه هذه المنطقه التي اقامت فيها
الدوله التركيه اليوم العديد من المخيمات
والعديد من الكرفانات المسبقه الصنع
للنازحين من انطاكيا نحن نتحدث اليوم عن
زلزال استمر اكثر من عشرين ثانيه على
الاقل نحن نتحدث اليوم عن خوف ورعب حقيقي
يعيش هو السكان اليوم في انطاكيا يعني ما
تبقى من السكان الذين يقتلون الان في
الصلاه الرياضيه وفي الحدائق العامه هم
الان يعيشون في حال الزعر وحاله خوف قويه
جدا نحن نتحدث عن ايضا عن مباني هذه
المباني كانت متصدعه وكانت اعلنت قد اعنت
الحكومه التركيه
بالامس انه سيكون هناك عمليات ترميم لهذه
المباني والعوده لسكان هذه
اليوم يعني ربما تدمرت ربما تضررت بشكل
اكبر لن يكون هناك عوده قريبه لاي من
السكان الى انطاكيا ونحن تحدثنا عن ذلك
وركبنا كل هذه التفاصيل ولكن عمر قلت بانه
هذا ما عشناه هو زلزال ثاني كما وصفته هو
ليس هز ارتداديه كما وهي بالالاف في
الحقيقه منذ زلزال الاول
دامت 20 الى 25 ثانيه حدثني عن التفاصيل
بما انه الارتدادات فيما قبل كانت تصل حتى
الى اربعه فاصل هذه المره سته فاصل حدثنا
عن تفاصيل
الفروقات التي عشناها بالامس كان هناك
هزات نشعر بها ولكن لا نشعر بالرعب الذي
عشناه اثناء الزلزال الذي اصاب انطاكيا
ولكن هذه اللحظات التي حدثت قبل قليل هي
هي نفس الشعور ونفس الاحساس الذي عشناه
اثناء الزلزال هناك يعني رعب ما طبيعي رعب
جدا كان يعني في القلوب هناك حاله من
الخوف التي عشناها قبل قليل فيها جراء هذا
الزلزال لانه فعلا نفس الشعور ونفس
المباني المباني المباني تميل يمين ويسار
يعني هناك الارض ارتجت من تحتنا بالكامل
وهذا ما ميزنا من خلال ان هذه ليست هزه
اعتياديه بل ان
هذا قويه هزه قويه ولكن عمر السؤال الذي
يطرح نفسه منذ زلزال الاول
المباني على الاقل التي صارت فيها تصدعات
تم اخلائها بالكامل اليوم هناك صور اوليا
وردها لمشاهدينا نرى فيها عدد من السكان
يهرولون الى الشارع خرجوا من بعض هذا
الزلزال او من بعد هذه الرجل الارضيه التي
قدرت قوتها ب 6.4 وبالتالي بقيه المباني
يعني هل هناك سكان هل هناك مباني عاليه
فيها طاعي لازال يقيم فيها بعض السكان
جميع جميع السكان اليوم يعيشون ضمن
الحدائق العامه مثل حديقه السوريين في وسط
انطاكيا وبالاضافه الى منطقه الدفنه التي
كان مركزها الزلزال يعني منطقه الدفنه
اقامت فيها الحكومه التركيه بعض الكرفانات
وبعض المخيمات من اجل السكان الناجحين لا
يوجد في الممالي ولكن ما يزال في انطاكيا
مباني عاليه وكبيره لن تتاثر كثيرا بل
تصدعت في الزلزال الاول هي اليوم ستطعت
اكثر بعد هذا الزلزال الثاني ولم
تعد السكن ابدا على الاطلاق ولكن بعد هذا
الزلزال الثاني ليس هناك سقوط لمباني صحيح
هناك تصدعات كبيره في منازل انا احد احد
المنازل التي اسكن فيها منزلي الان في
انطاكيا كان بالامس ربما استطيع العوده
اليه بعد الان لا استطيع العوده الى منزلي
في انطاكيا تحت اي ظرف كان هناك يعني بغض
النظر عن موضوع ان هناك التصدع الكبير
هناك حاله من الخوف الحاله النفس
يه جراء
هذا الاسباب الوضع صعب والله يكون في
عونهم الجميع عمر ساترك لك بعض الدقائق
ربما تستعلم اكثر عما يحدث اعود لك ربما
بعد قليل ينظم لنا زميلنا زيدان زين كلو
زيدان اهلا بك معنا
6.4 قوه زلزال جديد وليس
ارتداديه كما يقول البعض كيف هي الصوره
زيدان هل تسمعني
طيب سنعود لزميلنا زيدانكلو بعد قليل
مشاهدينا نعيد ونذكر بهذه المشاهد التي
كنا نتابعها هذه الصور من حلب الان
نردها لمشاهدينا ونتابع تفاصيل ما تحدث به
المركز الوطني لزلازل بسوريا الذي اكد
كذلك هذه الهزه الارضيه اكد قوتها سته
فاصل ثلاثه ويقول بان مركزها اسكندرون عند
الحدود مع تركيا اذا المركز الوطني
للزلازل بسوريا يتحدث عن هزه ارضيه بقوه
6.3 مركزها اسكندرون
وهذه المنطقه اي منطقه اسكندرون تقع عند
الحدود مع تركيا قبل ذلك كان الاعلام
التركي تحدث عن ان هذا الزلزال دمر ابنيه
كانت
ايله للسقوط في انطاكيا منذ قليل عمر
جبلاوي الصحفي السوري من انطاكيا تحدث
كذلك عن بعض البنا او بعض البنايات التي
تصدعت والتي تضررت كذلك من بعد الزلزال
الاول وقال بانه هناك
هروله للشارع وهناك خروج محاوله للخروج
لخروج السكان
فربما نعود له بعد قليل الاستطلاع الاوضاع
اكثر هذه صور مباشره من
من انطاكيا صور مباشره من انطاكيا ونلاحظ
فيها بان البعض يجري
طبعا هربا محاوله لايجاد مكان امن
يبقى في نذكر بان هذه المناطق مشاهدينا هي
اساسا مناطق عاشت زلزال هو الاقوى منذ قرن
هذا الزلزال دمر الحجر واودى بحياه الالاف
من البشر عائلات شردها هذا الزلزال
واعداد قتله فاقت الاربعين الف في تركيا
وبالالاف كذلك في سوريا سواء في المناطق
التابعه لسيطره النظام السوري وحتى في
مناطق
التي تقع تحت سيطره المعارضه معنا الاستاذ
عباس شراقي
خبير
الجيولوجيا استاذ عباس اهلا بك معنا استاذ
عباس ما الذي يحدث زلزال ثاني قوته 6.4
كيف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من 10 وبالتالي الاذنين الابتدائيه وفي
الحضر وفي الكتله الاراضيه قد يكون في
الارتداد كبير ايضا وده اللي احنا شفناه
يوم سته فبراير ولنا في زلزال 99 ايضا
شفناك تسال 90 ثواني
لمده ثلاث شهور
بعدها حصل زلزال قوي شدته سبعه واربعه من
اذا كل شيء جايز في منطقه
كذلك فرضيه اخرى بان يكون هذا الزلزال هو
زلزال اخر سوريا تتحدث عن مركز
في منطقه اسكندرون تركيا تتحدث عن مركز في
منطقه دفنه
وحضرتك خبير جيولوجي استاذه عباس الى اي
مدى زلزال ثاني قادر ان يكون منفصل عن
الاول هل هذا قائم وقادر ان يكون
من الممكن ان يكون
مختلف عن زلز من عشره وكان يبعد عنه
بحوالي 60 كم وبالتالي فهو في منطقه
منفصله مختلفه فممكن اي جلزال اخر يكون في
منطقه اخرى واللي حصل في تركيا ان زلزال
الاول الكبير عمل تحسين ليه بقيه الفوالق
الموجوده في الكتله التركيه وشفنا بعض
الزلازل المتوسطه
خمسه حدث شرق اسطن ده اول امس وكان ده
برضه هذا هو المكان اللي كان فيه زلزال
سنه 99 اذا هناك مجموعه من الزلازل في
كتله الاناضول في اماكن متطرفه لان الكتله
ضخمه
في شارع الامازون الا ان الامر لا نستطيع
ان نجلب ان هذه الزلازل توقفت او ان هناك
جنازل في سوالف اخرى
بتنشط من زلزال الاول
سلاسل اخرى تنشط من الزلزال الاول كيف ذلك
يعني الزلزال الاول هو الذي حفز طبقات
لتتحرك مثلا هو الذي
بما اننا لا نتحدث عن رجات ارتداديه فكيف
لزلزال ان يحفز زلزال اخر بمركز جديد
كتله ضخمه طولها حوالي 1200 كيلو متر
وعرضها حوالي 500 كيلو
من الجنوب في شان اللي عليه الزلازل
القويه في الفتره الحاليه وفي الشمال هذه
الكتله منفصله من الشمال بف اخر اسم فارق
شمالي الاناضول اللي حصل عليه زلزال سنه
99 هذه الكتله حصل لها انها اندفعت في
اتجاه البحر المتوسط بمقدار حوالي 8 متر
اذا الفرق الشمالي اتحرك
والكتله نفسها اتحركت لان هي مفصوله من
الجنوب
شرق الامازون ومن الشمال مغسوله بفارق
شمال الاناضول
وبالتاليتين حصل عليهم حركه
الاخطر ان فيها هناك ايضا يعني شيء وان
شاء الله نتمنى ان لا يحدث ان هناك براثيم
تعليم
المناطقين نشط في سنه 1440
تتحدث عن براكين في براكين في تركيا ولكن
اعلم ذلك ولكن براكين ميته او براكين
نائمه لانه هناك براكين تكون نائمه لفتره
سنوات وقادره مثل هكذا تحركات ان توقظها
هناك
سنه 1840
وبيقع في منطقه الشرق الاناضول
الحاليه هذا البركاني يعني التاريخ احنا
بنعتبر قريب في تاريخ الحديث
من الاف السنين بلوم السنين
اعذرني على المقاطعه استاذ عباس الموضوع
جد مهم وساعود لك لمحاوله فهم تداعيات ما
يحدث ولكن اسمح لي ان اعود لك بعد لحظات
بعد ان اكون مع زمينه زيدان زنكلو
زيدان اهلا بك معنا حدثنا عن تضرر عدد من
المباني في جندريس شمال غرب سوريا جرى
زلزال ما هي تفاصيل
بالضبط هل هو هل كانت هزه في انطاكيا بقوه
7.64
جديد بانتظار تاكيد من افاد هيئه الطوارئ
التركيه لكن ايضا بعض
دعينا نقول هذا الكداديه حتى الانتظار خبر
رسمي بعد الهزمه الاعتداديه في التي كانت
6.4
هناك ايضا
في ولايه من انطاكيا 55
تم سقوط عدد من الابنيه بحسب ما رفضناها
من قبل وسائل الاعلام التركيه طبعا انا
كنت في المنطقه قبل ساعتين فقط غادرنا
انطاكيا والحديث الان او اصدرت هيئه
الطوارئ والجواز التركيه تحذيرا بجميع
السكان بالابتعاد عن المباني المتصدعه
وايضا عدم الوقوف قرب المباني والبقاء في
الشوارع والالتزام بالتعليمات سنه الطوارئ
المتواجده اصلا في ذلك المكان يعني نحن
اليوم كنا هناك تقريبا كل المباني
المتصدعه مهجوره مدينه انطاكيا غالبيه
منطقيا في مدينه انطاكيا هم في المخيمات
واماكن ايواء مؤقته لذلك يعني الان
السلطات لا ترجح يعني او يعني هناك لا
ترجح وقوع ضحايا
يعني حتى الان لا نعلم حيثيات بشكل صحيح
لكن من خلال ما شاهدناه هناك قبل ساعتين
المساكن تقريبا تماما المدينه كلها فلذلك
استثناء بعض الضواحي التي لم من الزلزال
الاول طبعا شبكات الكهرباء كانت مقطوعه
منذ الزلزال الاول واليوم كانت الفرق
الكهرباء تعيد صيانه او تحاول صيانه شبكات
الكهرباء في الطرق الرئيسيه في محاوله
الرئيسيه لكن حسب المعطيات الحاليه ايضا
هناك انقطاع
سنؤكد هذه المعلومه بعد قليل بالعموم حاله
الهلع ارتدت الى كل الولايات لان هذه
الهزه شعره بها سكان
ولايات عنتاب وشال اوروبا والشمال السوري
وهناك هاله من حاله من الهلع في تلك
الولايات
الكثير من السكان اساسا هم ما زالوا في
حاله صدمه من الزلزال الاول نزلوا الى
الشوارع هناك حاله من القول حقيقه لا سيما
في مراكز المدن طبعا في مدينه غازي عنتاب
الكثير من السكان بعد ان سمحت لهم السلطات
للعوده الى مناز لهم بعد التاكد
وفحص المباني
عديد المباني الان عدد السكان اليها لكن
مع هذه الهزه التي جاءت وشعر بها سكان
غازي عنتاب واورصه عدد او غادر المواطنين
المتوقعين هناك هذه المنازل ونزلوا الى
الشوارع مع تحذيرات كما ذكرت من قبل افاد
او هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه بضروره
الابتعاد عن المباني والالتزام بتعليمات
الخواقل الطوارئ الموجوده هناك اعود لك
بعد دقائق زيدان حتى ربما هذه الدقائق
ربما تمكنك من محاوله التاكد من الكهرباء
من وضع هذه المباني لان هناك في الواقع
كميه معلومات تصلنا عن انهيار بعض المباني
عن جرحى كذلك بانهيار مباني في مدينه
تايلباب وحارم شمال سوريا جراء هذا
الزلزال وكنا نتابع من تركيا كذلك من
الجانب التركي في هاتاي بعض المشاهد
الجديده زيدان ساعود لك بعد قليل جمعه كاش
جمعه اهلا بك معنا جمعه ما الذي يحدث
المشاهدين يعني حوالي نصف ساعه ضرب زلزال
بقوه 6.4 درجات على مقياس ريختر مدينه
انطاكيا التركيه القريبه من اغلب المدن
على الجانب السوري حيث وقف هلا في صفوف
المدنيين ونزول من المباني والمنازل
باتجاه الشوارع لا يزال يعني العشرات من
الناس في الشارع ويتجهون باتجاه القرى
مخافه حدوث اي هزات ارتداديه اخرى وسقوط
مباني سجلنا حتى الان يعني تضرر عدد من
المنازل في بلدات سلقين بريف ادلب وجندير
سبيريف حلب وايضا في الاتارب هناك معلومات
عن وجود يعني مصابين وعالقين تحت انقاض
احد المباني التي انهارت في مدينه الاتارب
نقوم حاليا بتوثيق هذه المعلومات والتواصل
مع دفاع المدني في مدينه الاتارب لكن هناك
تضرر لبعض من المباني في سلقين وفي جنديرس
تحديدا ولكن هذه المباني التي سنتاكد طبعا
من
حالها وحال سكانها ولكن هذه المباني كانت
تصدعت جراء زلزال الاول صحيح وبقي فيها
السكان او هي مباني لم تتضرر
وهذا الزلزال الثاني اضر بها او اسقطها
في في سلقين وفي جنديرس وحارم والاتارب
هذه البلدات الاربعه كانت الاكثر تضررا
بالزلزال
زلزال زلزال الماضي لكن بعض من المباني في
هذه يعني البلدات لم تكن قد تتضررت بشكل
كامل يعني معظم المباني كان متضرره لكن
السكان بسبب ظروف البرد الشديد بسبب يعني
تاخر المساعدات يعني عادوا الى الى بعض من
هذه المباني والمنازل خاصه المنازل
المؤلفه من طابق واحد رغم انه كان هناك
نداءات كثيره بعدم العوده الى هذه المنازل
لكن السكان عادوا
في مدينه حلب عدا عدد كبير من السكان الى
منازلهم هناك الان خروج يعني من من هذه
المنازل يعني باتجاه مره اخرى الارياف
وايضا الناس بدات يعني تاخذ سياراتها
وتغادر يعني البلدات
بشكل كبير بالهزه الارتداء بالزلزال او
الهزه الارتداديه لكن هناك سقوط لبعض
واجهات المحاله التجاريه سقوط
يعني واجهات بعض
المباني وايضا ما نسميه البلكونات ايضا
سقطت ثلاث بلكونات في في بلده سلقين وهناك
حديث عن وجود يعني عالقين في مدينه
الاتارب تحت الانقال لربما يكون هناك مبنى
قد انهار لا نعرف بالضبط حجم المبنى وعدد
العالقين تحت هذا المبنى لكن هناك يعني
نوع من يعني
الضبابيه حتى الان بالحصول على المعلومات
لكن
هناك سلخيل مستلقين
كبيره تصلنا جمعه
اترك لك بعض الوقت اعود لك بعد قليل نتاكد
من بعض المعلومات حتى طبعا
نقرا في تفاصيلها ونحاول كذلك ان نفهم ما
الذي يحدث هذا الزلزال مشاهدينا نذكر بانه
زلزال كان بدرجه سته فاصل اربعه
وطال تركيا سوريا واحس به كذلك سكان لبنان
وفلسطين لبنان معنا زميلتنا غنوه يتيم
غنوه اهلا بك معنا
كيف هي الصوره حسيتي بزلزال غنوه كيف هو
الوضع
نعم شعرنا بهم قالوا بانه يعني لبنان هي
هزه في لبنان هي موجات بسبب ما حدث في
تركيا انتقلت هذه الموجات الى بيروت وكافه
المناطق اللبنانيه في طرابلس خرج سكان
مدينه طرابلس خرجوا من منازلهم لانه
بالطبع هناك الكثير من الابنيه المتصدعه
وهذا الامر يحدث دائما عندما يكون هناك
هزه هناك تخوف لدى اهالي طرابلس بالتحديد
من قوه اي هذا قد تتسبب في
هدم المباني حتى وان كانت هزه خفيفه لكن
حاله الهلع هذه يعني ربما اعتادها
اللبنانيون ليعودوا بعد دقائق بعد دقائق
الى منازلهم لكن هذه الالفه كانت بالفعل
اقوى من الهزه اقوى من الهزتين التي شعر
بهم بهما سكان لبنان خلال الاسبوع الماضي
كان في في نفس اليوم في يوم يوم الجمعه
كان هناك هزتين
لكن الهزه اليوم التي شعروا بها كانت اقوى
حتى الان لم تحدد قوه القوه الهزه التي
شعر بها سكان لبنان ولكن بحسب المعلومات
بان هناك تفاوت في
مدتي ان المده التي شعر فيها السكان في
مختلف المناطق ليست المده
غنوه وانت تتحدثين طبعا وتصفين الوضع في
داخل اللبناني نحن نشاهد صورا من تركيا من
هاتاي بتحديد هناك تجمعات في الشارع وكنا
اوردنا بعض الصور الاخرى لخروج بعض السكان
من مباني خروجهم للشارع ومحاوله الهروله
لايجاد اماكن يحتمون بها الان هذه الصور
تاتينا من هاتاي مشاهدينا على اثر هذا
الزلزال الاخير التي قيمته الجهه التركيه
بقوه 6.4 ونلاحظ في هذه الصور الى جانب
هذه التجمعات هناك سيارات اسعاف كذلك
تتنقل فلا نعلم ما مدى
تداعيات هذا الزلزال وكيف هي الصوره هذا
الزلزال مشاهدينا والذي تحدثت اداره
الكوارث التركيه وضعت المواطنين للابتعاد
عن المب القايله للسحور اداره الكوارث
التركيه كانت تحدثت عن هذا الزلزال وقالت
بانها هزه ارضيه قويه تقدر بسته فاصل
اربعه على
مقياس ريختر وبان هناك طبعا محاولات
لمحاوله او محاولات لايجاد طريقه للاحتماء
طبعا لترك المباني
المتداعيه والتي اضر بها الزلزال الاول
غنوه اعود لك هل هناك محاولات على الاقل
[موسيقى]
لايجاد طريقه
معينه للاحتمال خاصه بالنسبه للمتساكنين
الذين يتواجدون في بنايات قديمه او هذا
غير وارد
غنوه طيب فقدنا الاتصال بالزميله غنوه
يتيم لا نعلم ان كان ضيفنا عباس شراقي
استاذ عباس اعود لك كنت حضرتك تتحدث ونحن
سنبقى في الواقع مع هذه الصور التي تاتينا
من هاتاي التركيه ولكن كنت تتحدث عن
تداعيات يمكن ان تكون تداعيات جدا ثقيله
وقويه على اثر الزلزال الاول
ما المنتظر يعني ما الذي ترجحه في هذه
المرحله
اولا الزلزال حصل منذ حوالي نصف ساعه هذا
زلزال قوي
سته فاصله ثلاثه او اربعه
انا زلزال في مكان مختلف عن اماكن الجنازل
اللي حدثت الايام الماضيه هذا زلزال يبعد
عن سواحل التركيه
وبالتالي هذا مكان جديد
هنا خطوره هذا الزلزال او شده قوي
يؤثر اكثر على السواحل السواحل التركيه
والسوريه
ومن الممكن العدد بكربه من السواحل فيما
يتسبب في سلاله وسلامي بشده زلزال يعني هو
يواجه مباشره قبرص وتنتقل هذه الموجات
الى راحل السوريه واللبنانيه
ممكن تصل خفيفه الى مصر
الزلزال يختلف عن الزلازل الاخرى السابقه
لانك الزلازل
الاخرى بالقرب ويبعد عن مراكز بحوالي 100
كيلو اما الان فهو على الشواطئ التركيه
ومن هنا ياتي خطوره جميله تكون السابقه
بمياه البحر
الان سنتحدث نائب رئيس التركي يطالب
المواطنين بالابتعاد عن المباني فيها طاي
بسبب الزلزال اذا تصريح لنائب الرئيس
التركي يطالب فيه المواطنين بالابتعاد عن
المباني في هاتاي بسبب الزلزال مشاهدينا
من المناطق التي تضررت كثيرا من بعض
الزلزال الاول
وهذا الزلزال الثاني كما وصفته مصادر من
الداخل التركي من بينها اداره الكوارث
التركيه التي اعتبرت بانه زلزال جديد وهذا
الزلزال بقوه سته فاصل ثلاثه
اذهب الى ريف حلب او قبل ذلك هناك صور
طيب صور للحظه الزلزال مشاهدينا نتابع هذه
الصور
وهذه صور من خطاي التركيه
نلاحظ هروله المتساكنين الذين خرجوا
من المباني وهناك
اهتزاز للسيارات
هنا نتابع اهتزاز السيارات بطريقه
الصوت الطبيعي لهذه الصور الحيه التي
اتتنا منها
رعب والهلع الذي يعيشه متساكن هذه المنطقه
بعد زلزال اول اودى بحياه الالاف وتضررت
منه وعائلات الان زلزال ثاني
وهزه ارضيه قويه تزيد عن السته درجات في
انطاكيا التركيه احمد ابو لؤي صحفي مريف
حلب احمد اهلا بك معنا كيف هو الوضع هزه
ارضيه قويه البعث احمد تسمعني
نعم نعم اسمعك نعم بالفعل يعني الهلع
الخوف في صفوف السوريين اليوم او في هذه
اللحظات نجد المئات من العائلات انهمروا
هربا هلا عن خوفا في الشوارع في الطرقات
في عده مناطق بشمال غربي سوريا جنديرس
عزاز عفرين الدانه
بسلقين عده مناطق طبعا حتى الان لم يرد اي
انباء عن وقوع اصابات لكن يعني التخوف حتى
كبيره من
اسمح لي على المقاطعه فقط لان هذه صور من
ادلب الان تاتينا وهذه صور كيف
شعر سكان ادلب بهذه الهزه الارضيه التي
فاقت السته على سلم او على مقياس ريختر
هذه صور منذ قليل هناك من يجري في الشارع
هناك من يهرول وهناك وجوه متفاجئه في
الواقع لما
نتابع هذه الصور نفهم بان هناك حاله
ارتباك قصوى لان الزلزال الاول تبعته هزات
ارتداديه ولكن هذا الزلزال تقول المصادر
الرسميه التركيه بانه الاقوى منذ زلزال
الاول كذلك هناك حديث من الداخل السوري عن
سقوط مباني تركنا لزملائنا بعض الوقت
لنتاكد من هذا الموضوع لان هناك كميه
معلومات لدى الان عن سقوط مبنى كان تضرر
من بعد الزلزال الاول وكان تصدع من بعد
زلزال الاول وحتى هناك سيارات اسعاف كنا
نتابعها في هاتاي مثلا التركيه التي
شاهدنا بان هناك سيارات اسعاف كانت تتوجه
الى بعض المناطق لا نعلم كيف هي الصوره
حتى الان ولكننا الاكيد باننا سنبقى في
متابعه هذه التفاصيل اعود لك احمد من جديد
تفضل اكمل كنت حدثني عن تفاصيل اللحظات لح
هذا الزلزال الثاني نعم كما ذكرت يعني
الهلع الخوف حتى الان يعني انا الان في
الشارع في الطريق يعني ارى المئات من
العائلات
هاربين تحت هذا البرد القارس يعني هلا عن
خوفا يعني اوضاع يعني ارتباك كبير توتر
ضمن صفوف السوريين طبعا
يعني هو الاقوى هذه الارتداديه او لربما
الزلزال هو الاقوى من الهزه الاولى يعني
اليوم يعني تجاوزت الست درجات في التفاصيل
او 6.4 طبعا يعني
الخوف يعود من جديد الهلع يعني كما ذكرته
ضمن الاستضافات السابقه السوريين دائما
خائفين من هذا الموضوع من جديد وعقد يعود
كما نراها اليوم النساء
جميعهم الان من جديد بعضهم من طبعا طبعا
عاد منازلهم مت
لم ولم يستطعوا
من جديد لان يعني طبق طويله كما هو ظاهر
يعني سيارات
يعني المدني احمد الصوت يتقطع ولكن وضحت
الفكره تقول بان هناك حاله هلا وحاله خوف
طبعا اتت من بعض الزلزله الاول فكيف اذا
كان هذا الزلزال
قوي فهناك مخاوف كذلك على هذه المباني
المتهالكه في الاصل طالما تتحدث من سوريا
فاسمح لي ان انقل هذا العاجل كذلك الذي
تابعناه منذ قليل اسفل الشاشه الدفاع
المدني شمال سوريا يدعو الاهالي للابتعاد
عن المباني المتداعيه
المتضرره من الزلزال الاول اذا الدفاع
المدني شمال سوريا يدعو الاهالي للابتعاد
عن المباني الاليله للسقوط والتي كانت
تضررت منذ الزلزال الاول من جنديرس او من
جرابلس من جنديرس من جنديرس من
رمضان الو نعم معك انستا معك
رمضان سليمان رمضان اهلا بك معنا من
جنديرس عسوريه تفضل رمضان جنديرس من
المناطق التي حسست سكانها بطريقه واضحه
بهذه الهزه الارضيه القويه والاقوى يقول
البعض منذ زلزال الاول ما الذي حدث نعم
نعم حدث زلزال مرعب وحاله هلع اصبحت جدا
قويه لدى الاهالي في جنديرس نحن سمعنا
رمضان رمضان اسمح لي قبل ان تكمل اشير الى
هذا العاجل نائب رئيس تركيا يقول نواصل
جمعه المعلومات بعد الزلزال الجديد في
هاتاي يبدو باننا اثنان نحاول جمع
المعلومات نحن ونائب الرئيس التركي اذا
نائب الرئيس التركي يقول نواصل جمعه
المعلومات بعد الزلزال الجديد فيها طاي
ونحن كذلك ستبقى العين على هذه التفاصيل
وهذا مطار هاتاي اذا هذا هذه المشاهد
لمطار هاتاي منذ قليل
نلاحظ هناك ارتباك على وجوه الموجودين على
هذا الفيديو ومحاوله لفهم ما يحدث خاصه
وان ما حدث منذ ايام ونتحدث عن الزلزال
الاقوى منذ قرن كما
وصفته تركيا الرسميه
اعقبته بعض الهزات الارتداديه ولكن هذا
الزلزال يعد الاقوى منذ الزلزال الاول
هناك من يحتمي بالكراسي هناك من يحتمي
بالجدران في هذا المطار وستبقى العين على
هذه الصور ربما نستمع لصوت الطبيعي ونعود
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا بتكون نتابع هذه الصور صراخ الاطفال
هناك
محاوله للهرب وهناك وجوه اخرى
مرتبكه وتتساءل ما الذي يحدث في الواقع ما
الذي يحدث هذا ما نود فهمه نائب ارايس
التركي منذ قليل يقول بان الجهه التركيه
تحاول جمع المعلومات
لفهم الاضرار لفهم التداعيات ولفهم الصوره
كذلك بالكامل لما تضرر او للمناطق التي
تضررت من بعد هذا الزلزال الثاني اعود لك
احمد اعطني قطعتك منذ قليل كنت حدثنا وتصف
لنا صوره من عندك تفضل
احمد اذا فقدنا الاتصال باحمد رمضان رمضان
معنا رمضان تفضل
انا الان من امام المشفى الوحيد الميداني
في مدينه جنديرس
مدينه جنديرس لا يوجد فيها اصلا عدد قليل
من السكان لكن الاهالي المتواجدون كلهم
خرجوا الى الشارع
اتت الى المشفى بعض حالات الاغماء ومن
الخوف والرعب في مدينه جنديرس هرب الجميع
الى الشارع لم يبقى احد في المباني وهي
المباني متصدعه وظهرت الاصوات وسمعنا
جميعا هذه الاصوات والاطفال والنساء
والرجال هربوا الى الشوارع نعم كانت قويه
والابنيه متصدعه والابنيه
سابقا هي
مهدده بالانهيار
ولكن رمضان فقط لافهم منك لما تقول بان
هذه الهمزه بالتحديد كانت هزه قويه ونحن
نعلم بان منذ الز لزال الاول كانت هناك
هزات ارتداديه من بعده فاقت حتى الاربعه
وهناك اربعه هزات ارتداديه وصلت للسته
لماذا هذا الزلزال يعتبر الاقوى مقارنه
بكل الهزات الارتداديه التي سبقت
بالنسبه
الابنيه هي متصدعه
وقابله للانهيار فاتى هذا الزلزال فاصبحت
الابنيه صوتها واضح
والناس اصبحوا في الشوارع
فكان خوف وهلع كبير لدى الاهالي
المتواجدين في مدينه جنديرس حتى الاطباء
حتى الممرضين تركوا مبنى المشفى الميداني
وخرجوا الى الشوارع
وهناك حاله ارتباك ولكن هل هناك اماكن
قادر
او هناك قدره على الاحتماء بها في هذا
المناطق خاصه
لا يوجد اي منطقه
يستطيع الاهالي اول كادر الطبي نفسه ان
يحتمي فيها الان الاهالي في الشارع
سارعت فرق الانقاذ سارعت فرق الدفاع
المدني السوري في تجول في مدينه جنديرس
البحث عن
ابنيه متساقطه البحث عن
جرحى او اصابات الحمد لله في مدينه جنديرس
الى الان لا يوجد اي اصابه ولا يوجد اي
قتله لكن
ونحن نتحدث ونحن نتحدث دائما كل ما تردنا
صور حيه جديده
نحاول ان نعرضها هذه صور من هاتاي لانقطاع
التيار الكهربائي وخروج السكان في الشوارع
رمضان ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر ساشكرك جزيل
الشكر الله يسلم الجميع فيما تبقى من هذه
الساعه اجمل مشاهدينا ما اوردناه من اخبار
في اخر هذه العواجل مركز ابحاث الزلازل في
البوسفور تسجيل 9 هزات ارتداديه منذ وقوع
الزلزلين بهاتاي التركيه اداره الكوارث
التركيه تتحدث عن زلزال بقوه 6.4 وثاني
5.8 يضربان هاتاي جنوب البلاد